Oh Moffat now you just make it a mess
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we have arrived at the end of
series six which means we are going to
talk about the wedding of River Song
yeah a mess is kind of the best word for
it when I'm dealing with a Moffatt mess
I'm usually dealing with one of a couple
things every now and then I'm dealing
with something that at its core concept
is already a messy concept and there are
other times where some of the core ideas
are okay but just the execution is wonky
this one has a little bit of both there
are core concepts in here that work but
the fact that this was crammed into a
single episode
this is nuts because the amount of stuff
this episode is doing in terms of
bringing us full circle around to the
doctor's death this entire concept of
time stopping and somehow happening all
at once yet at the same time unraveling
has to be introduced and be meaningful
we have to tie off the silence we've got
to cover what's going on with River we
need to cover the fact that the doctor
didn't actually die and how that
happened and everything like this thing
is just it moves at a breakneck pace
because there's no way it couldn't with
everything that has to do and it's one
of those instances where some of the
concepts I wish weren't in this and were
done elsewhere where they could have
room to breathe the big one being the
entire idea of all things are happening
at once for all intents and purposes
nothing's really done with that concept
and that's a really neat idea and sort
of the way it's visualized of like this
overlapping of
past present future all happening at
once and every system oast people seem
to think that that's just the world
that's a neat idea
but at the same time it doesn't really
impact the story all that much I mean
River failing to kill the doctor did
need to throw the throw things out of
whack in some way but I feel like that
idea was bigger than just being the way
time has messed up I feel like that's an
idea that was big enough that it should
have it should have been explored more
fully than it is here
and speaking of River not shooting the
doctor Wow that scene doesn't work at
all and it's just the drastic gear shift
of it because you've got the doctor with
River you know the visor goes up they
have this very tearful exchange she's
like going it's the suits gonna make me
kill you and I can't stop it which first
of all pause hold on if the suit is what
is making her do it then why do they
need River I'm a little bit confused on
this entire thing at this point because
I guess conceptually I get the silence
creating River so that they could
basically fight fire with fire like well
a Time Lord appears to be more or less
insolvable let's make our own but when
she doesn't exit when she doesn't finish
the job why does it still need to be her
then because it's I I don't know I mean
there's probably like some weird
explanation either a tossed off line
that I missed or forgot or in some extra
thing or I'm sure people have theories
but once she's no longer willing to kill
him I don't understand why it needs to
be her other than like if you're gonna
do the recursive loop argument of like
well she does and it's a fixed point so
it always has to be hurt but set that
aside for saying I'm saying why why does
the silence need to keep using her if
they're gonna have to force her by means
of a suit that is in their control
anyway what is the value of being her
over literally anybody else or even just
being the suit
by its I don't know I don't know it's
weird but anyway getting back to the
scene the gearshift doesn't work because
it's this intense build-up to her
getting ready to blast him and then the
blast happened and he doesn't die and he
just looks at her and she's just smiling
like huh like what No
so just the the implication is one of
two things either she was basically
faking the trauma up to that point then
just dropped the Act which look river
had is is certainly questionable at
various points but that that's psychotic
that's emotional torture she's putting
the doctor through that and not like the
fun and flirty way she kind of messes
with him like that's screwed up
um so it's either that or she just
somehow miraculously wrestles control of
the thing at the last minute and yet
somehow it's no big deal to her that
doesn't make any sense either that shift
doesn't work if you're gonna make the
decision that her failing to kill the
doctor is what breaks everything fine
but like it should have been for the way
the front half of that scene scene is
built up it should have been like a Big
O and she manages to expel the energy
without getting him like making it this
casual thing just doesn't work at all
but then we get we get into the messed
up timeline thing we get a ton of
characters back and you know these
little offhanded ways we have Charles
Dickens again we have the Silurian
scientist we've got Winston Churchill
and that's kind of fun yeah I mean we're
gonna do this cool fine that's that's
fine
Amy being badass commander with the
eyepatch I do kind of like that I kind
of dig it and the the banter going on
with her Rory I enjoy once the doctor is
brought to river in this frozen timeline
bit their banter then that I buy that I
get and especially because once he touch
like things get serious and she's not
joking when things are being serious
yes um and I and I think there's some
validity and to exploring the idea of
what happens trying to trying to stop
fixed points in time since fixed points
in time is a thing that's been tossed
out by the show a few times up to this
point and the only time we've sort of
messed with it a little was waters of
Mars but even that the doctor was sort
of riding a fine line of well
technically things more or less still
happen the same way because the thing
the reason it was a fixed point in time
and then he saved them was that was that
a delayed granddaughter was supposed to
be inspired by her death he just as well
you just inspire her in real life course
she still dies because she kills herself
as a big middle finger to him but you
know the the doctor was sort of getting
off on a technicality in that one he
didn't just flat out stop the thing that
was supposed to happen from happening he
just massaged did a bit questionably
irresponsibly but he didn't just
straight up no that's not gonna happen
so we haven't seen that before
that's an interesting enough idea to
sort of explore and like I said if if if
they wanted to do that and to further
explore the what is being done with time
and this then I wish they weren't also
trying to tie off the silence and Madame
Kovarian and set up the next series
because again it's just too much and as
far as the silence goes I've reached a
point well actually these shoes isn't
the sight well it sort of is because the
silence is technically the religious
order it's not strictly those beings but
let's be realistic we all use it to mean
them anyways I have reached the
conclusion that I don't like Madame
Kovarian as a character and some of the
performance is bad she gives a perfectly
good performance for what she's being
asked to do what she's being asked to do
is kind of dumb so and here's what I
mean by that
given that the stated goal of the
silence is to basically ensure that the
universe doesn't come to
because of the doctor while that does
make them the functional antagonists
from the doctors perspective that's not
an unreasonable goal to be trying to
attain so I'm annoyed that Madame Madame
Kovarian is such a mustache twirling
style villain
you know gleeful in the failure of
others in the and the torment of people
that she's fighting against and what hit
me about that in this and this episode
is given her goals and what she's trying
to do there is no reason for her to be
as spiteful as she is other than to make
her as much of a straight-up villain as
possible I should think it would have
been way more interesting if she was
more conflicted if she was doing this
because it's what had to be done and
didn't appear to be taking any pleasure
out of it but watching this episode and
thinking back at her appearances she
took Glee in what she put the doctor and
Amy and Rory and River through she
really took joy in that and there was no
reason for that to be the case and I
actually think it's kind of boring that
they did that given that her intent
could have been seen as misguided but
some variant of noble and the thing is
the silence kind of get away with it
because you just look at them they look
weird and intimidating but we don't
actually have any personality off the
silence so while they are always scary
that's just a function of how they're
designing how they work within the story
Madame Kovarian we have the performance
we have the lines and it's like it's
just it's just villain to a degree that
I actually find dull and I don't think
benefits anything going on to be
completely honest about it so there's
that I do like Amy taking her out though
I find that to be cathartic and I also
kind of like that Amy's implying
you weren't the only ones who gave River
ruthlessness she's my kid she got some
of it from me
so that was cool and I and I dug that
the whole wedding thing it's a really
kind of a cheap fake out that we are led
to believe that this is the time when
River tells the doctor I'm sorry the
doctor tells River his name I understand
that he had to lie to Amy and Rory and
say something that they would understand
was something that they wouldn't have
any business asking River and that was
just what he picked so like functionally
within the scene I get it but like meta
textually for us as an audience this is
that's a cheap fake out as and honestly
the tesselecta in general is it the
whole thing feels like it was reverse
engineered the more I think about the
tesselecta as a device at all I think it
I think it was created to serve a plot
function as opposed to something that
they thought would be neat and then
figured out a way to use later on the
plot which would make it feel more
organic instead it really does feel like
Moffat went okay I need a way for the
doctor to be in a location and to appear
to die and technically he's there
because he needs to be how could I do it
well put him in a in a basically
indestructible suit that looks exactly
like him
and then reverse engineer the tesselecta
out of that narrative necessity but it
again it just feels very mechanical I
mean it is it's a robot but I mean I
mean narrative it feels it feels very
mechanical and it's used in the
narrative it doesn't feel particularly
organic and yes but you know even
looking back on its on its earlier
appearance
dorium he was kind of fun you know when
he showed up that worked well enough the
whole especially now in hindsight
knowing what does or doesn't come of it
but the whole the first question that
must never be asked Doctor Who
it really irritates me especially it
paired with other stuff that goes on in
the scene where we hear that so the
doctor says I've been too noisy I need
to retreat to the shadows and I remember
thinking at the time a terror like yes
thank you
he's been made too big and grand let's
let's get him back to basics and I
thought those what they were gonna be
setting up except it's then like Doctor
Who is like I'm sorry the first question
the question hidden in plain sight
across all time and it's still gonna end
the year so even if he tries and
retreats to the shadows you're still
basically making him the single most
important thing in the universe and I
don't like that and I never will I don't
yeah it's it's a case of it's a case of
the showing contradicting the telling we
are being told that the doctor is going
to make himself less important and we
are being but we're being shown through
the story and this dog is now coughing
oh my god but we are being we are being
shown through what we learn from dumb
which I guess opposes is also a form of
telling okay fine it's to tellings it's
contradictory but we're being told that
no but the question of Doctor Who is
somehow the greatest and oldest question
in the universe is like elf God's sake
those concepts don't gel at all the
performances are fine nobody gives a
particularly bad performance in this
it's just the the story is cramming so
much stuff together that it just it's
piling on top of each other there's a
lot of specific little somewhat nitpicky
details that don't work for me there's
some of the grants some of the big
picture ideas don't work for me and I
will say I did I I do genuinely like the
moment they give with the Brigadier and
I like it for two reasons first of all I
like the acknowledgement of the passing
of the actor Nicholas Courtney and I
also like that
I like having that be the moment that
makes the doctor decide to go and face
his death he then figures out a way to
weasel out of it but I like that that's
the pivot moment because I'm sure the
doctor had thought in his head there
always will be time I can get to this
there's always gonna be time it's fine
and just a reminder that death comes for
everybody and time catches up with
everybody sort of makes him realize you
know I could put this off but what good
is it gonna do
I like pivoting his his decision to go
and face his death on that moment I
think that works quite well I thought it
was a was a small and little touching
tribute I did like that but overall the
episode is just it's just a mess it's
doing too much the ideas are convoluted
some of the ideas need a more room to
breathe some of them didn't really need
to be there enough at all the stuff
that's being set up for next series I
don't think is being set up well and a
lot of it doesn't even really feel like
it factors in properly into the next
series all that all that much and it's
just it doesn't infuriate me the way
Moffat EDD is worse can infuriate me and
I'll have to figure this out I'm gonna
have a really hard time deciding whether
to rank this or let's kill Hitler one
above the other I have a feeling they're
gonna be close because I have similar
similar issues with both of them in that
you know there's there's good bits good
moments sound ideas but execution
especially on the writing level it's
just jumbled there's too much happening
and if it if it was a two-parter maybe
it would have the room to breathe and
have the shifts in the emotional beats
work as opposed to turning out a dime at
some of the points that it does a it's
definitely one of the weaker series
finales for modern era Doctor Who and
that's the wedding of River Song what
are your thoughts on it Yuri watched it
lately whatever your thoughts are
drawing something down in the comments
and let's talk about it there's a bunch
of stuff to do as well because you can
support me on patreon that's really
appreciated link in the description plus
you know the like the SUBSCRIBE all
those things are great
there's other links to other stuff
besides but you don't have to click on
any of it I definitely appreciate it but
end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]